hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we're going to be discussing ourselves
an often overlooked species of magical
beings from within the Wizarding World
specifically we're going to be diving
into their Origins taking a look at
where they came from and how they got to
be in the position that they're in today
house elves have been an integral part
of Wizarding Society for centuries
serving as loyal Companions and helpers
to Wizarding families but what's
interesting is that we're never actually
fed much info on the history did house
elves precede the existence of witches
and wizards when did househelves first
come to be what inspired JK Rowling to
create them why do they serve and just
how did they evolve into such an
essential aspect of the Wizarding World
I also want to examine how house cells
were used to symbolize deeper themes of
social justice equality and the ethics
of servitude hopefully through our
examination of their history we'll
uncover the powerful messages JK Rowling
intended to convey through highlighting
the mistreatment of an entire species
marginalized in society without further
do let's dive in what is a house elf in
Harry Potter house elves are magical
creatures that are bound to serve their
masters willingly and without question
standing at a diminutive height
measuring around two to three feeds
ourselves possess petite and slender
bodies atop their tiny bald heads they
have large bat-like ears these ears are
not just for show mind you they enable
ourselves to detect even the faintest of
sounds making them excellent at
fulfilling their duties and ensuring
they are ever alert to the needs of
their masters they can often be seen
wearing small pieces of fabric
resembling tea towels and can only be
freed from their servitude through an
ancient and magical Bond called the
giving of clothes but don't let that
small stature deceive you for their
magical powers are far from small in
fact from what we've seen in the Harry
Potter series it almost seems like
they're more powerful than a lot of
witches and wizards one of the best
examples of their magical Mastery is in
their Advanced ability to operate in
addition to operation ourselves possess
the power to perform magical tasks with
great accuracy they are unique unique in
their abilities to perform menial tasks
like cooking and cleaning with A Touch
of Magic making them valuable Assets in
any household these abilities exemplify
an extraordinary level of efficiency and
skill which is crucial in their
servitude one of the most noteworthy
traits of house elves is that unwavering
loyalty towards their masters they take
their duty of serving their masters
seriously we'll go to extreme lengths to
accomplish the task assigned to them
this loyalty also signifies their strong
values of honor and commitment however
the dynamic between Wizards and house
selves also raises a whole bunch of
ethical considerations which we'll get
into later
how self Origins we first introduce the
concept of ourselves in the Chamber of
Secrets when Harry meets Dobby the
resident house elf of draco's family and
the family's home Malfoy Manor through
this introduction we discover that the
upper class of The Wizarding World all
seem to own ourselves elves who are
magically bound to serve their masters
and work in servitude for well-to-do
Wizarding families without compensation
their tasks range from cleaning to
cooking and running errands all without
question and in the goblet of fire at
least the novel version we're introduced
to even more house elves the ones
employed by Hogwarts becomes abundantly
clear right away that the very existence
of house elves is based around servitude
with many of them locked into a kind of
magical enslavement as they're passed
down from one generation of a Wizarding
family to the next we also come to
discover that the only way they can
escape their enslavement is if their
Master gives them a piece of clothing
this aspect of how self-servitude is put
on display in the Chamber of Secrets
when Harry helps Dobby to secure his
freedom from Lucius Malfoy and the
Malfoy family
but when did all of this begin what was
the Catalyst for elves serving was it
kind because the origin of ourselves is
not clearly explained in the series the
door has been left wide open for fans
speculation one popular Theory among
fans is that house elves are actually a
creation of wizard kind made with magic
for the express purpose of serving
magical High Society
the issue with this Theory however is
that elves are a long-standing and
prevalent race among other works of
fiction if JK Rowling had decided to
create a wizard-made creature I don't
see why she would have recycled a
creature that's so common among other
magical universes furthermore the fact
that house elves are called ourselves in
the first place would suggest that there
are also other kinds of elves if other
elves do in fact exist freely in The
Wizarding World that it makes it even
less likely that they are a creation of
wizard kind unfortunately on the topic
of other types of elves we're met with
another dead end another theory which
takes into account genetic traits
Evolution and natural selection is that
how cells were simply domesticated by
Wizards imagine this long ago deep
within the enchanting forests and hidden
Realms of The Wizarding World witches
and wizards first encountered a rare and
undocumented species known as wild elves
these elves unlike their domesticated
counterparts possessed a fiery Spirit of
freedom and an untamed magic the defied
conventional Wizarding practices and by
employing a combination of Enchantment
and gentle persuasion wizard kind
gradually began to teach the wild elves
the ways of The Wizarding World however
Spellbound by their unique powers and
the potential for an extraordinary
Alliance wizard sought to brought these
wild beings into their lives not as
equals unfortunately but instead as
loyal Companions and helpers and in
exchange for the shelter care and
guidance offered by wizard kind the
elves gradually relinquish their freedom
and embraced their roles as loyal
household assistants I imagine it could
have started as more of an informal
arrangement in which Wizards offered
protection to elves and in return elves
helped out around the house perhaps it
started innocently enough with preparing
a meal or two or making the beds at the
beginning of the day but then over time
it's possible that the elves to provide
minded witches and wizards with better
service or in turn treated better the
more independent-minded elves may have
been cast out and possibly killed off
without the protection of wizards all
simply left without much opportunity in
the way of finding a mate after all like
many other species it's not impossible
to imagine that an elf with a job was
more desirable to a potential spouse
than one with no prospects from there
it's possible that Wizards further
manipulated the evolution of elves by
breeding the most obedient and docile of
the species with each other after all
visiting households only seem to have
one elf at a time which leads to the
question of procreation how is this
species continuing to reproduce
provided that house elves have
demonstrated an extraordinary Mastery of
magic in the Harry Potter Universe I've
often wondered why they would serve
wizard kind this Theory would help to
explain how and why they became enslaved
because they've been bred to enjoy their
servitude loyalty obedience and
punishments as we all know house elves
are famous for their unwavering loyalty
to their masters the loyalty is so
intense that they refuse to be set free
unless their masters present them with
clothes this Honor Code also drives them
to carry out their duties to the best of
their abilities even at Great personal
risk and sacrifice
it's not uncommon to find house elves
carrying out their duties even at the
cusp of death
however this intense devotion can have
dire consequences as we saw in the case
of regulus Black's house elf creature
who was unable to prevent regulus's
sacrifice despite his strong desire to
save him typically househelves take
orders from many people not only serving
a specific Master but also the whole
family of the master and anyone else the
master orders them to serve if they are
given an order from any of the
aforementioned parties they must obey
them the house elves the Master's orders
were considered the house elves highest
law in the event that a house self fails
to obey their Master they must engage in
some form of self-punishment one of the
most common and known self-punishment
methods utilized by house elves is known
as self-flagellation this involves
physically striking oneself often with a
whip or a sharp object as a form of
expressing guilt or atoning for any
perceived failures it is a way for them
to responsibility for any mistakes they
believe they have made real or imagined
the sight of a house self-engaging and
self-flagellation can be quite
distressing as it illustrates the depth
of their devotion and their willingness
to endure pain for their perceived
transgressions
another form of self-punishment employed
by house elves is self-starvation in
moments of extreme disappointment when
they feel they have failed their masters
house elves may choose to deny
themselves food as a means of chastising
themselves this act of self-deprivation
showcases their dedication and their
belief that they deserve punishment for
any perceived shortcomings the self-harm
exhibited by ourselves highlights the
harsh conditions in which they live and
the psychological toll to their
loyalty-driven servitude can take on
them but what is perhaps most
interesting and simultaneously
concerning about how selves is that they
actually seem to find some measure of
happiness in their enslavements there
are a few exceptions like Dobby who
yearned for freedom and Independence but
most househelves would actually feel
insulted if their masters offered them
payments pensions or reward that deviate
from simple acts of kindness house elves
find joy and pride in serving their
masters even if it means inflicting self
punished management torture or even
self-meming to please them house elves
and Hogwarts it shouldn't come as much
of a surprise that when discussing the
history of house elves we are brought to
Hogwarts School of Witchcraft and
Wizardry in fact the househelves brought
to Hogwarts by founder Helga Hufflepuff
are the earliest ones on record during
the early days of Hogwarts 10th century
when the castle was just a glimmer of
the Majestic Fortress we know today the
founders recognized the essential role
house elves could play in maintaining
its operations these magical beings
became the invisible threads that wove
Hogwarts tapestry of magic and order
from cleaning the common rooms to
assisting in the kitchens househelves
ensured that every nook and cranny of
the castle was cared for with utmost
dedication
helgafulpuff is officially credited with
bringing the house elves to Hogwarts
which makes sense as they were
originally enlisted with the task of
helping to prepare the Hogwarts feasts
and though they were technically still
bound to servitude bringing them to a
place with good working conditions was
the most moral choice available at the
time rather than serving just one family
the house elves of Hogwarts served the
school itself there was a little bit
more to the relationship between the
founders and the house elves then simple
servitude the househelves of Hogwarts
are valued a lot more than the one still
confined to disrespectful Wizarding
families they were Guardians of the
castle Secrets custodians of its history
and keepers of its magical Essence and
in return the househelves displayed
unwavering loyalty and dedication to
their beloved Hogwarts today in a
post-battle of Hogwarts era many house
elves still inhabit the Hogwarts Castle
at least a hundred little elves were
standing around the kitchen bowing and
curtsing has probably led Harry past
them but there are some notable changes
the verse being that after aiding the
good guys in the Battle of Hogwarts the
elves of Hogwarts became even more
respected by staff and students alike
and to those who were still on the fence
about the place of househelves in
society this pushed them over the edge
and forced them to reconsider the level
of respect that they should be giving
them additionally some of the
househelves of Hogwarts began getting
paid for their work at the castle an
entirely New Concept that many had
difficulty accepting while many of them
Embrace their new income many rejected
the notion that they should be paid for
their work maintaining their insistence
that they are simply bound and happy
deserve without compensation spew while
we're on the topic of Hogwarts house
elves it would be criminal not to
mention spew AKA The Society for the
promotion of elfish welfare
created by the other compassionate
Hermione Granger in 1994. the spear was
an organization dedicated to advocating
for the fair treatment and rights of
house elves in The Wizarding World
Hermione originally wanted to call the
organization stop the outrageous abuse
of our fellow magical creatures and
campaigned for a change in their legal
status but as the long and complicated
name wouldn't fit on a badge Hermione
eventually settled for spew Busey
Hermione's heart was deeply moved by the
plight of house elves who were bound to
serve their masters without any regard
for their well-being or Freedom
determined to bring about change she
sought to raise awareness about the
mistreatment of ourselves and to
ultimately secure their Liberation you
know ourselves get a very raw deal it's
slavery that's what it is that Mr Crouch
made a go up to the top of the stadium
and she was terrified and he's got a
Bewitched so she can't even run when
they start trampling tents why doesn't
anyone do something about it armed with
Badges and leaflets she tirelessly
campaign for the rights of house elves
urging her fellow students and even
professors to take notice and join her
cause she firmly believed that house
elves deserve to be treated with
kindness respect and most importantly be
granted the freedom to choose their own
destinies
but Hermione was nothing if not
persistent and determined through spew
she campaigned tirelessly for the rights
of households raising awareness of their
plight and advocating for their freedom
while her initial tactics may have been
a bit misguided her intentions were pure
and her empathy for these magical
creatures Shone through however it is
worth noting that the creation of spew
was met with mixed reactions while some
admired mani's dedication and saw the
Merit in her cause there were those who
dismissed it as misguided or unnecessary
even Ron Weasley Hermione's loyal friend
initially found spew to be overly
idealistic teasing her about her
activism nevertheless Hermione remained
undeterred demonstrating her unwavering
commitment to fighting for the rights of
house elves at one stage Hermione makes
the decision to knit clothes as a means
of freeing the Hogwarts ourselves
scattering the clothes around the
Gryffindor common room knowing that
househelves clean the space Hermione
hope that the elves would pick up the
clothes and gain their freedom however
many of the owls regarded Hermione's
actions as insulting resulting in the
househelves of Hogwarts refusing to
continue to clean the Gryffindor common
room
there is no clear consensus on what the
house elves thought of spew while some
house elves like Dobby were grateful for
Hermione's activism and recognition of
their rights as sentient beings others
such as winky felt that being a house
self was their Duty and that they should
serve their masters without question it
is worth noting that house elves like
humans have diverse opinions and
experiences and it is unfair to assume
that all househelves but shared the same
views on spew what the movement did
accomplish however was Raising awareness
about the treatment of house elves those
of you might not have achieved immediate
success it did leave a lasting impact on
the Wizarding World and sparked
important conversations about the
treatment of magical creatures it opened
the doors for dialogue and prompted
individuals to reflect upon the ethics
of enslavement and the fair treatment of
creatures who exhibited intelligence and
emotions house elves in myth the
househelves that appear in Harry Potter
are certainly not a novel Concept in
fact there are a multitude of different
figures spanning various folklords and
mythologies that closely resembled the
house elves in Harry Potter the first
and perhaps most notable example is the
brownie a type of household Spirit from
Scottish folklore they are small
hobbit-like creatures that are often
described as being dressed in shabby
clothes brownies are mischievous and
helpful creatures that are said to
preside in households or on farms they
are known to be diligent workers in the
dead of night completing chores and
tasks in exchange for small offerings or
tokens of appreciation
brownies are characterized by their
industrious nature and their willingness
to assist with domestic duties their
tasks include things like tidying up the
house sweeping floors milking cows and
various other household tasks which are
typically performed while the
inhabitants sleep one notable
characteristic of brownies however is
that they are quite shy and prefer to
work in secrecy often Vanishing or
hiding when they sense human presence
next up we've got kobolds in Germanic
folklore kobolds were mythical Sprites
believed to have originated in Teutonic
Germany they are sometimes depicted as
small helper Spirits or fairy beings
that live underground in mines or caves
but on occasion they are represented as
mischievous malevolent creatures that
enjoy playing tricks on humans
go balls are also believed to have a
connection to Fire and metal as they are
often found dwelling in mines or near
furnaces and forges some Legends suggest
that they can take on the form of
animals such as dogs or cats While
others describe them as small humanoid
beings with a distinctive hats or Hood
though they are commonly associated with
woods and mines kobolds also existed in
homes and were known for their helpful
nature in assisting with various tasks
within the home they would Aid with
chores and provide valuable services
the kobold seemed to differ from house
shelves and brownies and that they won't
tolerate disrespect where house elves
and brownies may bite their tongue
kobolds were known for being
temperamental and easily offended
becoming outraged for not properly fed
or mistreated the last comparison that I
want to make is to the domovoy the
demovoy is a fascinating creature from
Slavic mythology that has been a
prominent figure in folklore for
centuries like the other creatures
mentioned the dermavoy is believed to be
a protective spirit that watches over a
home and its inhabitants attested from
the 6th Century CE the domafoy is
believed to reside in a Slavic home
often near the oven behind the stove or
under the doorstep the appearance of a
dumb of oil can vary sometimes appearing
as an old man or woman and other times
taking the form of animals such as a pig
bird calf or cat most often they are
described as small bearded and covered
in hair with a distinctive graybeard
sort of like a miniature to wizard
interestingly there are even stories of
domovoy getting deeply attached to a
specific family serving them Faithfully
for Generations just like ourselves
other places they work while house elves
were often confined to the houses of
specific Wizarding families like the
blacks the crouchers and the malfoys
they were also known to work for a
multitude of Wizarding institutions
one such institution is makusa AKA The
Magical Congress of the United States of
America while not much is revealed about
the exact details of how self-labor in
makusa we do know that these
hard-working and loyal creatures were
employed in positions such as janitors
and Messengers in Fantastic Beasts and
Where to Find Them we see a scene where
a massive papers is being tidied up by a
house elf later in the film we see
another household sweeping the floor and
cleaning the U.S congressroom another
place we see ourselves working is that
the circus arcanas the circus arcanas as
you may remember from Fantastic Beasts
the crimes of Grindelwald is a magical
circus that travels around Europe
showcasing strange and wondrous
creatures to his Crowns While the
specifics of the conditions and duties
of househelves working for the circus
arcanas are unclear we do know that they
were mistreated and forced to carry out
dangerous and often humiliating tasks
for example one how self was seen
serving hot dogs to the circus as
patrons dressed up in a demeaning outfit
while being jeered at by the audience
another was subjected to performing in a
dangerous stunt that involved being shot
out of a cannon it's also been heavily
implied that house elves work at some of
the other visiting schools such as
durmstrang and bulbatore at these
schools elves was had to be responsible
for working in the kitchen cleaning the
school and transporting student luggage
notable house elves while house elves as
a species have certainly captured the
hearts of Harry Potter fans around the
world I want to highlight a few that
really stood out Dobby this courageous
household first appeared in Harry Potter
and the Chamber of Secrets and his
journey touched the hearts of readers
and viewers alike Dobby went against the
norms and risks to help Harry Potter
eventually earning his freedom from the
moment he ironed his own hands in Harry
Potter and the Goblet of Fire do his
heroic sacrifice in Harry Potter and the
Deathly Hallows Dobby showed us the
immense power of kindness and this
strength that lies within every house
self Winky Winky a house of belonging to
the Crouch family brought forth a
different side to how self-experiences
introduced in Harry Potter and the
Goblet of Fire winky faced hardships and
struggles as she navigated life after
being dismissed by her master Mr Crouch
her sadness and longing for her old life
shed light on the complexities of how
self-relationships and the challenges
they face when their loyalty is tested
and their freedom compromised Creature
if there's one household who underwent a
transformative Journey it's undoubtedly
creature as a member of the black family
creature's loyalties were tested until
his Fateful Encounter with Harry Potter
and his friends
in Harry Potter and the Order of the
Phoenix Harry treated creature with
kindness and respect ultimately winning
his loyalty greech's role grew even more
significant in Harry Potter and the
Deathly Hallows as he became an
essential asset in the fight against
Voldemort and proved that even the most
seemingly irredeemable characters can
change hokey while a relatively minor
character hoki the house of belonging to
the late hapsiber Smith played a crucial
role in the larger Narrative of the
horcruxes in Harry Potter and the Half
Blood Prince it is revealed that hoki
unknowingly played a part in the death
of hermistress and the subsequent theft
of Helga hufflepuff's Camp one of
Voldemort's horcruxes
hoki's involvement adds depth to the
history and consequences of the dark
arts and serves as a reminder of the
dangers that can befall house elves in
service to their masters while these are
just a few of the prominent house elves
that captured our attention in the Harry
Potter series their story shed light on
the complexities of how self-society
their struggles for freedom and the
extraordinary acts of Bravery they
displayed whether they faced immense
challenges or found strength in
unexpected places each houseof left an
indelible mark on The Wizarding World
house elf Liberation a question that
often comes up in discussions is what
happened to the house elves after the
battle of Hogwarts this is an important
question and one that deserves to be
explored it is mentioned that over 100
households turned up to fight for
Hogwarts during the battle their bravery
and loyalty were instrumental in
securing the final Victory against
Voldemort and his Death Eater Army but
what about after the battle according to
JK Rowling's writing on possible the
aftermath of the battle saw a shift in
the treatment of house elves Hermione
Granger who has always been a champion
for how self-rights emerged from the war
as a leading voice advocating for better
treatment and respect for these magical
creatures with the help of then minister
of magic Kingsley shacklebolt she
spearheaded a campaign to end the
widespread abuse and disregard for house
Health welfare as a result ourselves
gained new legal protections they were
given the right to wages and the freedom
to leave their current employers if they
were mistreated this was a significant
change as previously househelves were
seen as property without any rights of
their own additionally some of the
Hogwarts ourselves such as winky Dolby
and creature were afforded more respect
and autonomy they were given the option
to continue working with the Hogwarts
Community but now with the freedom to
choose when they wanted to work and how
they wanted to be treated overall the
outcome of the battle of Hogwarts was a
turn turning point for the treatment of
ourselves their contribution to the
final victory was visible for all to see
and people began to realize that these
magical beings were more than just
servants they were deserving of respect
dignity and autonomy this change in
attitude towards ourselves was a
significant step forward for their
rights and recognition within the
Wizarding World closing thoughts and
that concludes my deep dive into the
fascinating world of house elves in
Harry Potter through their stories we
learned valuable lessons about kindness
empathy standing up against Injustice
the complexities of loyalty and Freedom
the value of all types of Labor and the
potential for Change and Redemption
their Tales remind us to cherish the
magic within us and embrace our journey
of self-discovery and Enlightenment if
you enjoy the content please like the
video and subscribe to the channel until
next time remember it does not do to
dwell on dreams and forget to live